yesterday we set out to co-opt and
overshadow the first day of pride month
and although it didn't happen exactly as
I anticipated or planned I would say
that we we still succeeded so to quickly
review what we discussed on the show
yesterday here's the daily wire we
decided that we would celebrate the one
year anniversary of our film what is a
woman and ring in pride month 2023 by
releasing the film free for everybody on
Twitter and we presented this idea to
Twitter several weeks ago they were
excited about it at first they offered
us the chance to buy a special event
page for the film which would have all
kinds of great extra features and it
would also ensure a wide reach for the
film but then only a few days before our
streaming event Twitter changed its tune
dramatically they told us that they
decided that the film is hate speech and
that it violates its policies against
misgendering quote unquote policies that
they removed from the written terms of
service months ago but which they now
say still exist but in I guess invisible
ink Inc and they told us that we could
not have our event page and not only
that but if we posted the film on our
own page they would tag it as hateful
conduct and disable sharing on the film
and make sure that nobody sees it in
their feeds they told us that our only
way around this the only way to post the
film and not have its reach totally
crushed would be if we censored it ahead
of time by removing certain scenes that
Twitter found especially offensive and
we of course refused that offer and
instead resolved to post the movie
anyway and to have this fight with them
in public I mean if that's what they
wanted that's what they would get and
they got it that recapped everything we
covered on the show yesterday things
were left on a bit of a cliffhanger it
wasn't clear what would happen when we
posted the movie if Twitter would
actually make good on its threats to tag
it as hate speech and censor it what if
anything would Elon musk's Musk do to
step in and enforce his Free Speech
promises we didn't know any of the
answers to those questions we were
headed for a standoff and we weren't
sure what the result would be well
shortly after eight eastern time last
night we found out
we published the film as promised in its
entirety uncensored on The Daily wire
Twitter page and for exactly two minutes
everything went well in fact there was
so much interest around the film that in
just two minutes uh 3 500 people shared
it in two minutes
but then the speech suppressors moved in
making good on their threat to suppress
it two minutes after it was posted
Twitter slapped the hateful conduct
label on it disabled retweets disabled
uh comments and removed and blocked it
from everybody's feed so if you tried to
retweet it you would get a message from
Twitter saying that the content cannot
be shared because it interferes with
quote healthy conversations
and if that was not enough censorship
the phrase what is a woman was
blacklisted from the trending list and
removed every time it appeared there and
Twitter's actually been doing that for
the past year ever since the movie
originally released they've blacklisted
the film from trending and they kept up
that policy yesterday now at this point
Elon Musk started to speak publicly
about the issue though his initial
statements were somewhat uh unclear
somewhat ambiguous earlier in the day he
had said that the decision the sense of
the movie was a mistake made by many
people at Twitter and that it actually
doesn't violate any of their policies
yet in spite of of those statements it
was restricted and censored anyway in
response to that Elon said last night
that the problem would be fixed that the
hateful conduct label would be removed
and that sharing would once again be
enabled but he also in a series of
responses said that the the movie would
be Advertiser restricted and since its
sensitive content quote unquote it won't
be quote pushed to people unless they
ask for it now it was unclear what
exactly any of that means and and uh at
any rate even as he said all this the
movie was at that moment being actively
suppressed by Twitter so what does
Advertiser restricted mean does it mean
that advertisers control what content
Twitter users can see and if that's the
case then how can Twitter be a free
speech platform if advertisers control
it
and what does it mean that what is a
woman is sensitive content how is it
sensitive
anybody who uses Twitter knows that some
of the most vile obnoxious grotesque
actually offensive content
um regularly makes it into your feed
from accounts you don't even follow I
have on many occasions
as we all have if you use Twitter or
really any social media site uh you know
I've seen videos of people dying okay
videos that pop up in my feed
automatically play I don't want to see
them and I'm just scrolling along next
thing you know I'm watching somebody die
and that's apparently not considered
sensitive by Twitter
and of course I see all kinds of content
from the other side of the trans debate
none of which is ever labeled sensitive
or hateful why would our film which
simply asks questions to people on both
sides of the issue be singled out in
this way
and why would this happen on a platform
that has newly professed its commitment
to free speech
so these tweets from Elon were confusing
and the actions that Twitter was
actively taking against our film were
disturbing but the picture was made more
complicated by what we were hearing
privately you know the whole daily wire
team was at the office late last night
trying to coordinate our strategy you
know kind of a war gaming to you know
talking about how to fight back against
this censorship
and we were all uh getting texts and
calls from sources that we know who know
what's happening behind the scenes at
Twitter
and word was coming in from many
different places that Elon was according
to a lot of these sources Elon was
furious at his content moderation team
uh because of this censorship that heads
were rolling at Twitter headquarters
over this it was Perhaps Perhaps not a
coincidence that at this exact moment a
Twitter employee from the brand safety
team publicly announced his resignation
from the company this employee Mae ayed
is his name has a history of posting
tweets scolding and mocking white people
which is not exactly the sort of person
who should be involved in ensuring brand
safety whatever exactly that means
but if these are the kinds of people who
are leaving the company
it's probably a good sign
in the not too distant past private
citizens used to be largely that private
what's changed well the internet think
about everything you've ever searched
for watched or tweeted on the internet
now imagine all that data being crawled
through collected and aggregated by
Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there who
sell business involves buying and
selling your data they have to tell you
who they're selling it to or get your
consent one of these data points is your
IP address data Harvesters use your IP
to uniquely identify you and your
physical location but you can mask your
IP address with expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes my connection through an
encrypted server makes it more difficult
for third parties to find me it sounds
complicated but really you just have to
open the app tap one button on whatever
device you're using and you're good to
go if like me you believe that your data
is your business secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN on the market
use MyLink expressvpn.com Matt walshow
to get three extra months free that's
exp rssvpn.com Matt Walsh show
there was no clear resolution then on
the issue last night it was kind of
still up in the air well weren't sure
what was going on but we woke up this
morning uh things had changed at some
point overnight the hateful conduct flag
was removed from the film and sharing
and retweeting was enabled I started
getting messages from people saying that
not only could they share but the movie
was coming up in their feed and a few
hours later as the ultimate Capstone on
all of this drama Elon Musk himself
shared the film from his account with a
caption urging every parent to watch it
so it was a it was a wild ride for 24
hours it began with Twitter censoring
the film and labeling it hate speech
ended with the owner of the company
tweeting his endorsement of the film and
urging people to watch it
um so how do we make sense of this
well when it comes to Twitter I think
the most reasonable interpretation is
that Elon Musk is still fighting with
the leftist radical elements in his own
company
you know they're they're they are deeply
embedded in the company as they are in
every big tech company and given how
everything worked out it seems clear
that Elon intended for the film to be
distributed uncensored on the platform
but the woke elements inside the company
stepped in to sabotage it in fact um
this morning Elon confirmed that the
resignations on Twitter's trust and
safety team were he said directly
related to all of this the film the
controversy surrounding it
so which means that on top of everything
else what his woman has accomplished it
also appears to be helping to separate
the wheat from the chaff over at Twitter
headquarters which is a major
accomplishment in its own right
we can assume you know that there are
likely more woke foxes in the hen house
but the good news is that they're being
rooted out they're being exposed
which is all uh very encouraging
the other lesson that we learned is one
that we've learned many times in the
past already
which is that on this issue and really
any other issue the left cannot win in a
fair fight they they cannot meet us out
on the field in a pitched battle and
hope to Prevail they suppress and censor
and de-platform because they know their
position is insane they know it can't be
intellectually or morally defended
they know their arguments are laughable
and flimsy
they know that their claims fall apart
under the slightest scrutiny
if open here's here's the truth if open
discussion on this topic
of gender ideology
if open discussion was allowed
everywhere okay if everybody could just
say what they think about it everywhere
on all the platforms everywhere in life
you're not going to be censored you're
not going to be fired from your job
um you're not going to be arrested if
you live in Canada
if open conversation was simply allowed
their side would be crushed into
Oblivion in less than a day
okay it is as simple as that trans
ideology would disappear overnight
if the other side of the argument the
critical side was allowed to speak
openly
and actually be heard without
suppression or reprisal
the entire ideology hides behind a
fortress of censorship because it is
easily destroyed out in the open and its
proponents know that
that's why it would appear leftists at
Twitter were willing to sacrifice their
jobs for the sake of shutting this film
down
they broke our agreement they publicly
defied Their Own Boss
they was an act of self-immolation
perfect professional self-immolation
putting their careers on the line all in
an effort
to prevent people from seeing this film
and hearing the other side
that is uh that's how terrified they are
and in the end it was all for nothing we
win
you know I I will admit
um
and I wouldn't usually admit this kind
of thing but I will admit that
throughout all of this
I did feel a bit demoralized for a time
because even though I'm used to it by
now I know how these people operate
it can still be if you're a human being
it can still be deeply frustrating to
meet these artificial roadblocks every
step of the way you know it's one thing
to have the other side arguing against
us we Embrace that we want that
but they won't argue that's the
frustrating thing
they won't argue all they ever do is try
to shut you down silence you they refuse
to play the game on a level field they
just refuse
and after a while the constant onslaught
of censorship suppression demonetization
all the schemes you know you're always
running into something else every day
it's another thing
and it gets exhausting
with this film especially it's been
Relentless the movie's been
de-platformed banned censored Blacklist
blacklisted
like you can't even organize a watch
party for this movie
um
on on certain platforms on Eventbrite
like that's how that's how thorough the
Deep platforming has been and it's been
that way ever since its release
mainstream film critics refuse to even
review it
okay you remember that from from last
year we sent them screeners they
wouldn't even watch the screeners
and it has reached an enormous audience
in spite of all that and had a massive
impact but in my more cynical moods I
sometimes think about how much more of
an impact I might have had how many more
people it might have reached if the
powers that be weren't blocking and
suppressing us at every turn
fortunately though as I was feeling
slightly discouraged last night I had my
therapist Jordan Peterson on hand to
offer some counsel and he said something
that put it in perspective he said that
when you speak the truth whatever
happens is the best possible thing that
could have happened in other words
there's no use lamenting the
consequences of speaking the truth
because if you do not speak it if you
remain silent then the results will
always be worse anyway ultimately and
he's obviously right about that in fact
proving his point
now that the censorship has been lifted
and Elon has posted the film himself uh
it's fair to say that more people will
see it and hear about it than would have
if the left had never attempted to shut
us down in the first place probably
Millions more
so it all backfired the truth wins out
in the end
they won't play fair they never do
but even in the rigged game
when it comes down to it they still lose
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed